Sorry, I forgot where the apex tab was.
I was like, where was it?
That's why the video paused for a couple of seconds.
I was like, where's my apex tab?
Good morning, everyone.
Good morning.
I woke up like 15 minutes ago.
Let's fucking go!
1230 stream!
I love my 1230 streams!
Yeah!
Good morning, everyone.
Guys, did you guys notice?
We hit 700k subscribers!
We fucking did it!
Holy shit.
We did our very first official milestone together.
Zy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Congrats on 700k.
Thank you everybody!
Our first official milestone!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
This is our first one because like, you know, when we came back, we're like, I hope I get 500k before the end of the year.
And now we're at 700k.
It's absolutely fucking crazy.
I can't... I... okay, I...
I'm sorry.
I don't have a gift for you guys to celebrate.
It was just... there's so many things going on every day.
But don't worry.
There will be a belated gift.
It might be a...
a bit... it might be a...
month late.
But... but... I do have a belated gift for all of you guys to celebrate.
Bye!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's go!
Congrats on 700k.
Thank you!
Bite size.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A billion.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
I'm... I'm still like waking up slowly because like I said, I just... I literally just woke up like...
Uh...
...15 minutes ago.
Ittragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on 700k.
Remember when you thought you were gonna have less subs?
Good luck, I'll take an 8 later today.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys I am like...
I hope you guys are looking forward to the noose.
Guys, okay, I don't know if you remember this, but like, um, so during that I think that JP... Apex Legends tournament that we did.
You remember how like...
On that stream, I was like, oh, I almost leaked something for next season.
So what I almost leaked out for next season...
This was the season.
I almost leaked out the solo modes.
Because, you know...
I was told about the solos mode.
And the solos mode.
And the new legend.
And all that stuff.
And I was like, no, it wasn't the best season.
It was the JP, Apex Legends.
And I almost...
Because we were talking about solo stuff.
And I almost leaked out...
I was like, oh, you can do it next season.
Because there's solos mode.
And I almost said that.
That would have been such a huge oopsie.
Because solos mode is like a huge thing.
And I almost...
I almost said it out loud.
I was invited to the place...
Whoa!
I was actually...
You guys didn't know.
Okay, I don't know if I told you guys this story.
But...
I was actually...
I...
I was told what the next update was going to be.
So, there was like, you know, the new legend.
Which is basically like the better version of Wraith.
And I saw like gameplay of the new legend.
Because I also had like...
You know, I...
I have like...
A relationship with the...
With the Apex devs.
So like, you know, they would like tell me about what's going to be happening for next season.
And everything like that.
And then so...
So like...
They actually...
One of the devs actually wanted to invite me to LAN.
Because there was going to be an event at LAN or something.
I think they wanted me to do the solo...
You know, there's like the solo showcase.
And everything.
So like, one of the devs actually wanted to invite me to LAN.
With like, plane ticket.
And like, the plane ticket sort of...
Like, paying for my plane ticket.
And also like, the hotels and everything.
And then like, also like, getting to try out the...
The...
Getting to try out the new next season.
For at LAN.
But like, I had to refuse.
Because I also had like a lot of stuff.
I couldn't really travel anywhere at the moment.
Because I had a lot of stuff going on.
And also, I was like...
To be fair, I was also really paranoid.
Because I was like...
I don't want any photos taken.
Like...
Because I was like...
I was like...
Um...
Wait...
Is there going to be like other content creators?
And they were like...
Oh yeah, yeah.
Like, we're inviting a select few of content creators as well.
I was like...
Oh, okay.
And I was like...
I'll think about it.
Okay.
At that...
At this moment, I was like...
I don't really...
I'm a bit paranoid.
I'm a bit...
I was like...
Oh, I am a bit paranoid.
I feel like...
But I also had like a lot of things going on in the background as well.
So...
So I had to say no.
And I was like...
I would love next time.
Maybe next time I feel like a bit more safe.
Like...
I think it's also because of everything going around about me.
And then stuff like that.
I was also concerned about my safety.
So I was just like...
Well, maybe next time when things like die down a bit more.
So...
So I was just like...
If things die down a bit more...
I'll...
Maybe I'll try the next line.
I'll try the next one.
Brother, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
So...
So yeah, that's why I was like...
I was looking...
I was like...
Oh man, that looks so fun.
But like obviously like they're like...
Oh, like...
Whenever...
If you ever want to...
Like we are...
We'll definitely have an open invite for you.
If you want to try the next line or like the finals or anything.
Like if you want to come over.
Like we will...
We will like pay for your hotel and pay for your like plane ticket and everything.
And I was like...
Oh, fuck.
Sweet.
They're so nice to me.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah, there will always be a next time.
There will always be a next time.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just got back home from a 3 day trip.
Glad to be home.
And now you made it to 700k.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah.
It was really sweet.
Sweet of them.
I really love working with the Apex devs because they're super sweet and everything.
Anyway guys.
Anyway.
It's time.
It's time to check out the new Apex.
The new Apex gamemode.
I'm not going to do solos first because I'm a little scared.
I'm just a little scared.
Oh, shit.
There she is.
There's edgy race.
There we go.
This is going to be their reputation.
Oh, I can gift people?
Fuck no.
And she has a tail!
She has a fucking tail!
Look at that!
Oh my god, you know what she reminds me of?
She reminds me of that mutant in X-Men.
Fuck, what's his name?
What was his name?
What was that guy's name?
That's what she reminds me of?
Nightcrawler!
Yeah!
Like her toes even has like Nightcrawler looks.
Okay, her toes, sorry.
Look at her feeties.
Yeah, she looks just like Nightcrawler.
I feel like.
But yeah, she's apparently like the better version of Wraith.
And like more fun from what I'm told.
From like my friends that have like playtests.
And like when I tested her, she just looks like a...
What are her finishers though?
Dynamic Exit...
God, that's like...
Oh, it's like...
That ability reminds me of another character.
I can't fucking figure it out right now.
Oh, that's actually pretty sick though.
Bro, she's fucking crazy.
Bro, even the finishers are fucked up.
Alright.
And then they...
6 days left.
Oh, Broken Moon.
Wait, what?
Why is there six days of fucking rank?
That does not make sense.
Hey guys, I'm bronze now.
Anyway...
Demotion per- Oh, because everybody starts at zero!
Okay, we're gonna try her out.
Wait, actually, we're gonna try her out in firing range.
I forgot about that.
We'll try her out in firing range.
Let me see my volume.
It's okay.
Settings, audio, yeah, alright.
Alright, alright, let's see.
So, how the fuck do I use her abilities?
Oh my god, is this the range?
Oh no, that's out of range, okay.
That's like, holy shit, the range!
Oh wait, that's out of range.
Nevermind.
That was not the range.
Guys, you know I can't read.
Hahaha.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The legend is hot.
This legend is hot.
I'm reinstalling Apex.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Alright, let's see.
Okay, there we go.
It's like, how do I get this to work?
Oh, this is gonna be hard to figure out the range.
Alright.
And then what do I do?
Then what do I do?
Where the fuck is my portal?
Wait...
Hahaha.
Wait.
Where did my portal go?
Okay.
It's not like that.
Oh, wait, wait, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
Okay.
Alright, guys, I'm so... I didn't read the actual thing.
I should have read it.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me actually read.
Okay.
Get from the rip.
Can you interact with...
Okay, I know about this.
I've heard about this.
My friends who playtested this told me about this.
Q creates a passage through a surface.
Oh!
So it's like...
Oh my god!
I get it.
So like, if somebody locks the door, I can be like, no.
And then I go through the door.
Oh, I see!
I see!
So like, basically, it counters catalyst.
So they lock the door.
I can be like...
I can be like, no, bitch.
I'm in your walls.
Look, see?
There's like this door locked.
I'll be like, boom!
That's fucking right.
And I beat the shit out of that person right here in the corner.
Wait, can I drop from ceilings?
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, can you?
Okay.
Let's see.
We have 18 seconds.
What's the ult, though?
What the fuck is the ult?
Okay, wait, no.
Creates a regroup point that all allies can interact with to open the phase toilet.
Oh!
Yeah, so this is basically like a two-way ash portal.
I see.
Care package.
Reveal care package and see the highest...
Okay, we already know that.
Alright.
Okay, let's see.
Oh my god!
Oh, and you can go back up!
Wait, that's huge!
Look at that!
Oh my god!
We can actually, like, go from the ceiling!
That's actually pretty fucking cool.
Yeah.
Okay, let's see.
And then...
And then the portal.
Oh my god, we can drop down and be like, surprise, fuckers!
Okay.
Alright, we deploy.
And then open portal.
And then what happens?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wait.
I think I used it wrong.
I think I used the portal wrong.
Okay, give me a sec.
I was confused.
Where's the ultra gear?
I was confused!
Go far away and TP to...
Oh, it's a return point!
Oh!
Okay.
And then...
And then what do I do?
Oh!
And then we, like, run, run, run!
And then... Oh, we can go so far!
Look at that!
That's like how... Oh, wait, no, that's the second.
Oh.
Yeah, and then we go...
I come back.
And that's everybody, right?
Oh my god!
Wait, that is so cool!
Wait, that is pretty cool.
It's a return portal.
I feel like that's... Can I do it again?
Is that gonna be, like, there forever?
Can I do that again?
Why is it... Oh, no, I can't.
I can't do it like that again.
Yeah, this guy is like... It's like Nightcrawler.
And Shadowcat.
Thank you, Superchat Jesse.
Thank you, thank you.
That's actually really sick.
I think I like this better.
No, I think I like this the most.
Because, like, the fact that, like...
Doors are no longer the enemy!
I think that's the...
That's the most fun part.
No longer will doors hinder me.
She's in here once.
No longer.
Welcome back to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Doors and floors and ceilings, too.
You can never hide from Doki.
You can never hide from me!
Peek-a-boo!
What are those?
That's right, Catalyst.
You thought reinforcing your waz can stop me?
Nothing can stop me!
I'll just come in from the ceiling!
Alright.
Yeah, you can't hide from me no longer.
I mean, that's pretty cool.
I really like the abilities.
They seem really fun.
They seem like a fun character to play in general.
Now, the question is, will I be able to play her?
That's the question!
Peek-a-boo!
Alright.
Let's see if I can play her.
Like, oh my god, the way... oh my god, she's a fucking freak.
You know she's a freak.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Alan, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Atobe is suddenly coming from your ceiling!
True horror!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
That's a cute name!
She probably...
Nooooo!
Give me...
I'm streamer.
Ha ha ha!
No!
Let me play!
I stream!
Oh yeah!
I'll be the better...
I'll be the lesser version of you, I guess.
Ha ha ha ha!
I'm you.
But less.
Ha ha ha!
Yeah, look at my...
Look at my badge!
You could have had me on...
On the new legend!
Oh wait, he won.
Nevermind, maybe he is pretty good.
Ha ha ha!
I'm the last game.
Alright.
I'm you, but worse!
Ha ha ha!
No character on banner?
Welcome to...
I almost said welcome to Overwatch.
Because that seven hours of Overwatch still lives rent free in my head.
Also, how's the volume?
I forgot what the default sound was for Apex.
In general.
So like, I might have like...
I don't know if it's too loud or not.
Weeeeee!
Okay, nice.
I got Havoc.
That's seven hours.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
The wingman is back on the floor.
Alright.
It's back guys.
I know there's no like digi threat though on the wingy.
Did anyone else land here?
Hello?
Is anyone else here?
I don't feel like...
I don't think anyone else landed here.
Oh, Legend of Stock.
Thank God.
They've had it too good for too long.
Did you was deleted?
Yeah.
Did you guys hear the rumors of like...
Wait.
Did I hear something?
No, that's not it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, look, if you had the power that I had, you would abuse the shit out of it.
Don't lie to yourself, okay?
If you can, like, use it to your advantage, you win.
Just like how getting early access to things Marvel rivals.
So true.
Hey, can I have early access?
I'm a streamer.
You win!
If you had that opportunity, you would 100% do the same thing.
Thank you for the magenta soup, bud.
Thank you, thank you.
Why did he land us here?
There's literally nobody here.
All right.
Oh yeah, they took away skull piercer in a mag.
Okay, do you hear the rumors, guys?
That like, um...
That like, TSM might disband?
That's actually fucking crazy.
There's like rumors going around that TSM might...
Disband.
Uh, because of the perfo- Because of their performance in ALGS.
Yeah, because like, uh...
Verhos and uh...
Verhos and Reps tweeted out like very suspicious tweets today.
Uh, yeah.
Did you start those rumors?
Did you guys not see?
They were tweeting out some very fucking suspicious...
Uh...
Suspicious tweets.
They- not like the org TSM, but like the Apex.
Uh...
The Apex team are thinking about disbanding.
Which is fucking crazy because they're known as one of the longest teams to get it.
Like, I mean not- not like Verhos, but like- like Jordan.
Sorry, Reps.
I don't know why I said it.
I don't know why I said his first name.
Uh...
He's weird like 27 years old.
Alright, let's see.
Ultimate reduce, ultimate cooldowns, passive warms...
WOOOOOOAHHHHHHHHH You don't know him like THAT!!!
Yeah, it's actually wall the walls!
I'm in your walls!
Alright...
Alright, give me... holy shit, what a fucking head glitch.
That's fucking right.
I might not have played this for a while.
Wait, where are they?
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay, nice.
I helped.
There you go.
I fucking helped.
Okay, let's see.
Nice, we need that.
Well... don't worry!
Don't worry, guys!
I got you!
Okay, never mind.
He climbed.
Oh!
Oh my god, there he is!
Okay, where are you?
I'll hit those shots!
I hit it.
I did it, guys.
Did you see it?
Bacon, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
I have morals, okay, Doki?
I do things a good old way.
Old fashioned way.
Through bribery!
Yeah, but bacon, you know what's better than that?
When you can get things for free.
Dang.
Yeah, did you guys see that?
I hit all those shots.
I know, it just happened so fast.
It's a bit hard to see, I know.
Wait, am I getting shot?
Or did he shoot me?
I couldn't tell.
Wait, what's this?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's like a little barrier!
Wait, that's so cool!
Okay, all these changes, no, not gonna make up for the fact that Broken Moon fucking sucks, though.
And we're gonna have like several days of this, too.
Oh, they're near me.
Warn my teammates?
Nah.
Okay.
Where are they?
They're near me.
Oh, they're over there?
Alright, don't worry, I have my portal.
Do it again, don't worry, I got you.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, they're above me!
They were that near me?
Did they see me?
I don't think they saw me, guys.
I'm going on the roof.
I'm in your roof now.
There we go.
WHOA!
There we go, did you see that?
Oh shit, did you?
Whoa!
Did you guys see that?
Look at those shots I hit!
Whoa!
I killed him!
That was me.
Nice, look at you go.
Nice.
I knew I could deal with that.
Okay, tactical windup, reduce tactical windup.
Tactical cooldown.
I haven't played Raven so long.
I don't even know what her cooldowns were.
Okay.
Grab this.
That's your streamer.
That's me!
Okay.
Oh, wait, is she Chinese?
She just said, wait, wait!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, wait, is she actually Chinese?
That's so cool.
I just realized we've never had a Chinese legend yet.
Our streamer.
I was blinking against you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Those shots you thought I missed is because you were blinking so you missed the frames.
Yeah, she said, wait, wait.
See?
Look, this is how I was supposed to...
I am hitting those.
I almost pressed Q for a conduit.
I've been playing conduit for so long.
I'm going to go with that backpack from you.
Okay, maybe if I need him.
He's going to have to push up.
Yep.
Wait, where is he?
Is this...
Is that mine?
That's mine.
Okay.
Wait, why are you running?
Oh my god, he's tap strafing too!
Okay, maybe I should...
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Don't worry, don't worry, bro.
Don't worry.
Is he rising him?
No?
Okay, let's thrash them then.
Just in case.
Where?
I'm so confused.
Holy shit.
Okay, guys.
Does it look like I haven't played Apex often for a very long time?
I did play Apex two days ago just to be like, oh shit, new season.
But it doesn't look like I'm that rusty, right?
Right?
No, right?
I'm naturally talented, so I should look okay, right?
It's because...
Okay, I'll say it's because...
Let me aim it.
Oh, holy shit.
He's so far.
Look, I have a perfectly good excuse for this.
Okay, guys?
Because I'm playing Wingman.
Okay?
I'm playing Wingman, so that's my excuse.
And he's also playing Wingman.
Look, see?
He's not hitting his shots.
It's just a Wingman debuff.
Whoops.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I was not expecting him to just be there.
Look, I hit one.
Look, one is one.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait.
That's the Mirage.
Where the fuck are they?
This team is making me so, like, confused.
Where?
Where the fuck did he go?
Okay, let me loot this guy first.
Boosted Loader.
Do I need Wingman ammo?
I can't believe I actually need Wingman ammo.
Alright.
Look, it says I got two kills.
So, like, I'm not totally worthless.
Alright, here we go.
Where the fuck...
Where the fuck is the other team?
Alright, if I stand still, I won't get hit.
I'm gonna blow my nose.
Just give me a sec.
Surely, I won't get shot at.
All I'm saying is that the shots you don't see me hit are...
are the shots that...
Wait, if I use this, does it, like, expire for everybody?
Oh, they're near me.
Does it expire?
Or does it still stay up?
I actually don't know how this works.
No, everyone gets one use.
Oh!
Oh, I see.
Okay.
But, yeah, you think I don't hit those shots, but because...
It's your blinking.
You're blinking to the frames of me hitting shots.
You can hear it, but then if you don't see the visual...
the visual effect of the shot hitting, it's because you blinked.
That's...
It's so fast.
Yeah, you just couldn't register it.
Like, all of you guys, too.
I can't believe... it's like...
I can't believe all of you had that experience, too.
That's actually... What are the chances?
What were the odds of that happening?
It's like one to a million, and you were there.
It's like a natural phenomenon.
Pert lane.
Oh, shit.
Is this Horizon Q a new visual?
Oh my god.
Okay, this team is actually goaded.
What the fuck?
I did it.
Alright,
ooh.
There's the bow.
I feel like I hit more shots with a bow than...
than the fucking wall.
I'm going mad at this point.
Wait, behind us?
Wait, who do I go to?
I'm gonna go to the cat.
I did it, guys!
What is he trying to... chase?
Hello?
What does he wanna do?
They're close to me.
But I won't let them know that.
Gotta keep them... keep them on their toes.
I hear them.
Yeah.
Please.
I told you!
I hit more shots with the bow!
I fucking knew it!
Oh, shit.
I can't hear you.
I knew I hit more with the bow.
I should full heal, actually.
Look, it's been so long.
Wait, that is him.
I thought he was just like... a mirage clone.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should...
You guys!
I forgot!
When you climb, it cancels!
Hey!
Sorry.
Guys, they hit me!
Guys!
Oh my god!
The... the bullets like fucking...
curved, guys!
It was absolutely insane, team!
That bullet curve!
That...
Guys, did you see it?
They hit those shots!
It was insane!
The fucking bullet curve there!
Holy shit!
The bullet curve!
It was absolutely crazy!
Max!
I know, right?
Oh my god, they already got a kill!
I was there.
I'm gonna farm some damage so I won't look like total ass.
There we go.
Going one more team!
Yeah!
We did it!
First game!
I was part of this team!
Yay!
I was part of the process!
Let's just leave.
Let's just...
Oh, wait.
As a party leader, you can requeue the party if you exit at any time.
Wait.
What?
We'll also have to return to...
Oh!
Wait.
That's...
What?
No.
Fuck you.
Oh.
Oh, I wasn't the worst!
Guys!
I wasn't the worst one!
Wait!
I thought I did so little damage!
But I actually did just enough!
I didn't...
It wasn't me!
Guys, I realized I was actually good.
Oh my god.
I was just enough.
I was the middle of the pack, chat.
I was the middle of the pack.
I blinked it.
Oh!
Now you blink.
Now...
I was in the sandbag all this time!
I was part of the process!
I fucking knew it.
I knew I was in the sandbag.
Oh, thank god.
I can play this character now.
Middle...
I was average.
I was just enough.
Look, I did play Wraith, which was her, but worse.
She was mid.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
This is it.
This is me.
Yeah.
It's the new chat.
Um, already forgot.
That's me!
That's me.
I forgot her name already.
What's her name?
Ulter?
Is that her name?
No matter how much they change this map, this map will always be ass.
I changed my mind.
Sorry.
It was blinking too much.
Khaazouk!
Thank you for the super chat, bro.
Thank you, thank you.
Is it altered?
Yeah, okay.
Because it doesn't... changing the map doesn't change the size of this map.
Which is what was a huge problem.
Because the map was too fucking big.
I mean like...
Yeah, I just think the map is just too big.
I forgot Broken Moon existed.
We all want to forget Broken Moon existed.
This is like a nice cool designed place but still pretty fucking terrible map.
I don't think anybody likes Broken Moon in general.
I don't think anyone actually likes this goddamn map.
Hello.
Can I steal your stuff?
I want to do triple... actually I really want to play triple take.
For like one fight.
Because triple take is still an ass gun.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Oh wait.
Don't worry!
I got you!
Boom!
Where this is going to take me?
Oh, right here.
Alright.
Wait, where is the person that she's fighting?
I hear him.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
I see you.
Okay, I was going to say.
You better not die to that.
Because I literally like...
Whoa.
Hey thanks for the loot.
Nice.
Wait, what?
Oh shit, this is bad.
Waaaaait, this is... I was like...
Wait...
Two?
That doesn't add up.
This number.
This number does not add up.
How is there two when I killed two already?
I might be bad at math, but I know when numbers don't line up.
2 plus 2 equals 3?
That ain't right!
What the fuck happened?
Oh, it's the same team again.
We're running it back.
The non-existent win streak.
It's them again.
Alright, these guys better fucking pick up the slack, cause I got two.
I got my twos!
One of them- wait, no, actually, I got my ones.
Who was it?
Who did not get their ones?
She's meeting people up again.
Wait, this guy got a rookie badge.
What a fucking legend.
I wish I could get a rookie badge.
Awesome, thank you so much.
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
Sorry, I was blinking more again.
Okay.
Alright, you guys, run it back.
Run it back.
It's revenge time.
You're Diamond, you better impress me.
Who am I kidding?
He's Diamond.
He's already disappointed me.
Who am I kidding?
Alright.
Let's see.
Grab the G7 scout.
We're gonna get rid of the G7 scout cause I'm fucking terrible at it.
Oh, I hear people fighting in there.
In there?
In here, there's so many.
Oh, there's people.
I hear people next to me.
Or am I fucking going skitza?
No, there are people next to me.
I see them.
They went through the portal.
He doesn't see me though.
Alright, watch this.
Peek-a-boo!
Okay.
That was a little ambitious there.
He peek-a-booed back.
I didn't expect the peek-a-boo.
I didn't expect him to look back at me.
He knew.
He stared back into the void and shot me.
That's crazy.
I can't believe he shot back.
That's the craziest thing you can do.
Oh.
Wait, there's like two different teams here.
Oh shit, no!
Come on!
I did so much damage!
Hey guys.
Nice.
Steven, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Good luck on the new season!
Thank you!
Okay.
Oh no.
I need to grab the armor.
How do I like grab stuff from other people's inventories?
Because that should be like my special, right?
I should be able to grab stuff from other people's inventory.
Alright.
Extend highlight and see how far I can go.
Help bars after it reduces cooldown.
I feel like...
Extends highlight to help bars after exiting?
Really, that's good.
Just look from afar?
Oh!
Okay, I got this.
I understand.
I actually do understand.
I'm not like saying it.
It's not like the old I understand where I don't understand.
And I'm just saying it.
Just because I don't want people to think I don't understand.
Oh, there it is!
Alright.
But I actually understand for real this time.
Like...
I actually understand, guys.
And I'm not saying it.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got this.
I'm gonna help my team.
Wait, can I steal this?
Let's see.
Okay.
I can steal from each box.
Oh my god!
I can steal from each box!
Wait, that's so cool!
I love that.
I...
I fucked up.
I got shot by three people.
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
Maybe they're gonna swing.
I don't know.
Whoa!
Okay.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Are they still in that corner?
Oh my god!
No!
Please!
Why is everybody here?!
Please just shoot each other.
Okay.
I understand.
Don't worry.
They're shooting each other, guys.
He's right here.
He's gonna...
Loot, please!
Loot the box!
Oh, god!
My greed!
God, the better of me!
Oh, my god!
He used the portal.
Guys, I should have used the portal and ran through the walls somehow.
It's okay, we have a conduit.
That means like somebody's gonna... she can like craft us.
Look, I'm still learning the hero.
I'm still learning.
This is like my second time playing her, guys.
Come on.
Does she not have shields?
Where the fuck is her shield?
Guys, pick me up.
I'm important.
Guys, it doesn't look... oh, she's coming back.
Okay.
She knows I'm important, guys.
See?
I knew I was important, guys.
I knew I was the main character.
Even she knew I was important.
She came back.
How important was I?
I got my banner picked up.
That's important enough.
No stream... yeah, my streamer privilege coming in clutch again.
Oh my gosh.
I'm looking... I know like... okay, I was gonna say.
I know like... I said that...
I said that we were... you know... that this week was gonna be a rest week.
This week is not going to be the rest week, by the way.
You guys didn't know.
It's not!
Too many things came up last minute.
But I'm also like super looking forward to... I'm looking forward to Hades 2.
I was like... that like... oh my gosh.
The sudden drop... the Hades 2 drop out of nowhere.
That's actually crazy.
The fact that we have Hades 2 before anything about Silksong.
Like...
Silksong... I love Silksong.
Waiters out there.
Hades 2, let's go.
The Silksong copium.
Guys, no.
It's gonna come out soon.
You guys don't know that.
It's just...
It's just cause like Hades 2... Hades 2 is... is an early access.
But when Silksong comes out, it's gonna be full access.
You guys don't understand.
You guys do be like that.
Damn...
Anyway... anyway...
I was like looking up like... I was like... okay... cause it's early access.
And so I was like... okay... so like... how much content is actually in there?
And apparently... the majority of like... the story content is like actually almost done.
It's mostly just like the the little things in the game.
So... okay.
Okay, reduce tactical avoidance.
Next is no longer times out.
Wait, that's so cool.
Wait, where's my teammates?
Oh, they are far.
I'm gonna go to my teammates again.
Yeah, it's just missing the end, right?
Yeah, most of the gameplay seems to be there.
So like, it's just the little things.
It's just apparently the ending is not...
So like, it's technically like hours of gameplay, which is crazy to think about.
That that is early access and it's already like hours of gameplay.
Oh, goodbye, sir.
Okay, those shots were fucking nasty.
You have to admit that.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
They actually thirsted him.
Holy shit.
That poor guy.
That poor guy actually got thirsted.
Okay, you have to admit, that was a sick-ass shot I did on whoever this guy was.
Tom Lee.
I didn't even need to use my abilities.
Bro, panic ulted.
I mean, I would too after I fucking demolished his teammate.
Like, I'd be fucking concerned.
Okay.
I don't like the sound of that.
I heard nades.
But from where?
Am I hearing things again?
I might be hearing things again.
I'm gonna steal something from our teammates.
I wasn't hearing things.
I fucking knew it.
Watch this.
Peekaboo.
Oh.
Okay.
I saw the help bar.
I was like, teammate?
Wooo!
Not gonna lie.
I actually thought it was my teammate, but I forgot that was my ability.
I was like, wait a minute, help bar.
That doesn't make sense.
That actually doesn't make sense.
But it was...
I made it like that.
Teammate?
I'm not sure.
Alright.
Okay, I knew that was not teammate this time.
This time I knew.
Can I like steal something?
Ehh.
I'm gonna put this here.
Alright.
Here we go, we're fine.
I think there's like another team here.
I feel that there's like another team here.
Alright.
We can see something.
Where?
Where did you get shot?
This guy?
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, push.
Resim, Resim.
I'll protect you guys.
Resim!
I got you.
I'm covering.
Where is he shooting at?
Oh, it's the portal!
I was like, what?
Okay, that poor man.
Also, I realized I did not loot any shield cells.
Let me steal that shield cell real fast.
No!
I stole fucking health!
Okay, okay.
I just looted the old fashioned way.
I'm so freaking... I was like, it was just reflex.
It was actually just reflex for me to loot the first thing I see.
I was like, ooh, gold helmet.
That's a nice loot there.
Whoops.
Did not mean to press my Q.
What a team player.
That's a weird looking shield cell.
Alright, what else can I steal from there?
Wait, this is so convenient.
I can just casually steal things.
Alright, let's see.
Eh, let's grab the scope actually.
Wait, did he took the scope?
Wait, he took the scope!
There was a scope right here!
He actually took it!
That fucking madman.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, they took it down?
No, I took it down!
Whoops.
That was...
That was an accident actually.
I was like, wait a minute, where did it go?
Wait, it's one guy.
I think it's one guy.
Yeah, we were...
No, it was not one guy.
I didn't get one guy.
I knew I didn't get one guy.
Watch this guys.
I did it.
Did you watch it?
I told you.
Look at that.
He died without me even looking at him.
Oh my god.
I watched it.
Nice.
What?
What happened?
I was so good that he died from my mere presence.
That was how good I am.
Look, middle of the pack.
I take those.
I take middle of the pack.
Incredible.
Amazing battery.
What a fucking gamer.
I know.
Wait.
I think I got a cool... I got a cool icon.
What was it?
I got a cool badge.
What the fuck?
Oh, I was like, what is that?
I've never seen this before.
Where's like the legend badges?
Okay.
Where is it?
No, I won't be able to... No, I gotta win!
I gotta win!
It's the same team!
Fuck this shit.
It's not you.
I wanna play with new people.
I wanna play...
No, fuck it.
It's not them.
Guys, I just wanna play with new people.
Not three times in a row.
Okay, where is the legend badge?
To show people how much of a gamer I am.
Okay, only things I've unlocked.
Where is it?
Where's my face?
What the fuck?
I thought I unlocked it.
Did I not unlock it?
What?
Where?
Where is it?
Okay, let's see.
What did it look like again?
It was like... Oh, there it is.
Alter.
There you go.
Now they know I... Oh, now they know I won a game.
Cosmic, thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
Sorry, I got... Sorry, I got it in my...
Bro, fucking...
Wait, what?
Oh, JetPlay, man.
He wanted to play Rive 2.
Didn't he?
Just keeps happening.
No!
I should just leave.
Fuck this man.
Yeah, where the fuck is your Pred Badge?
JetPlane, man.
You really deserve to... Are you...
Are you even... Are you even Chinese?
That's making... I should be able to play...
Doki is tired of hard carrying.
I'm eating tangerine.
Tangerine.
Uh...
True.
Damn, can't keep it up.
I should get first choice.
Cancel that guy.
Right now!
They're pulling my streamer privilege.
Oh my god.
There's no gun.
Right bitch.
Shit on.
Oh shit, I'm gonna get shit on.
Literally have a P20.
Missed the first 50 minutes.
Can you give me a rundown?
I hit 100% the shots I took.
That's a TLDR.
You missed it, guy.
You missed it, man.
I won like five games in a row.
Oh my god.
Truly like the best streamer content out there.
There is another team here cuz I got scanned.
Are you a fucking coward?
I literally like killed one of them.
Why are you so scared of?
Where could he be though?
I know he's scanning me here.
He... wait, I see his scans.
I see you.
You scan yourself.
You revealed your location to me.
I should grab this actually.
I should grab the R9.
Here?
Whoa, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna run into his face.
Wait, where did he go?
I did it.
You saw that?
I hit my shots.
Wait, is he?
Is she speaking Cantonese?
Wait I... I can't tell.
She said something that seemed like Cantonese.
Does it matter?
Yeah, she speaks canto.
Yeah, I was like wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
That sounds so familiar.
I couldn't exactly tell what she said, but like...
Because it's like, not like...
Loud enough, I guess?
Are you running?
Oh, you have friends!
That's not fair!
You should respect this 1v1!
Oh god, oh god.
Somebody's not respecting the 1v1!
That's right, that's what you get for not respecting the 1v1.
Oh, that's right!
You can't fucking...
Alternate it!
He's right here!
Don't die or you're fucking bad at this game and you should honest up!
But not me, I wasn't bad.
I just got... I just got 3-partied.
That doesn't relate to me though.
That doesn't relate to me.
That's so cool though!
She speaks Cantonese.
I like, understand her.
Totally not bad.
It's not me!
It's never me!
I literally have streamer privilege!
What's the point of being a streamer if I can't use this privilege?
Like...
What's the point?
It's like when you're rich but you don't use any money.
It's literally the same thing.
Like...
Like, what's the point?
Okay, that was embarrassing.
That's actually so bad.
So Keanu Reeves...
Wait, the resin!
Don't let him do that to you!
Oh!
So true!
His streamer privilege is denied.
What?
Rich people stay that way because they don't use money.
What are you talking about?
Okay, that is not true.
Wait, he deseed?
What?
He fucking...
Alright, we leave.
We leave.
We fucking leave.
Wait, am I playing on...
Okay, I'm playing on full screen.
I guess we can try solos now.
We'll try solos.
There's no way that guy T's C.
Dude, this finishers...
I feel like there's like more characters with like...
I feel like I've seen...
I've seen like this finisher.
Like this type of move done before.
I'm trying to remember...
Oh!
Perfect Cell!
That's what it reminds me of!
It reminds me of a fucking Dragon Ball Z!
Yeah, I was like wondering like why the fuck does that kill?
Like it's so similar.
It reminds me of like...
More like Cell 1.
Yeah, I think it's like Cell 1.
Imperfect Cell.
Yeah, his first form.
Yeah, that's why I was like that's so familiar.
It looks like the... like a Cell finisher.
Yeah, now it makes sense.
Is she girl boss Cell?
Doesn't it like...
It just reminds me of the animation for Cell.
Oh yeah, nobody can steal it now.
Um, Maya, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alert, if you are seeing this message, you are in danger of a mysterious life form known as a woman derogatory.
Has breached containment.
Do not engage.
Lock all doors and windows.
Your virginity is at risk.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, Solo time.
Bracket derogatory.
Let's see...
We'll go...
I wanna go...
Where do I go?
Where do people go?
Okay, I'm gonna look at where all the other Solos go.
And then like...
Ooh, enemies nearby.
Tells me where the enemies are.
That's sweet.
Alright, so they're all here fighting each other.
I can take these little... little bit of loots here.
Ooh, glue!
Spitfire!
That got me off my guard.
Ooh!
Oh, they're all like... it's all like...
Uh...
Oh, that's interesting.
They're all like already kitted out.
Oh, I like that.
Okay, we'll grab the Havoc.
And then we'll go in.
I feel like playing as this character is not...
5 years, 21 seasons and I'm still trash.
My god.
Poor guy.
I don't know if playing as Alter would be good for this character.
I don't know.
For Soloist mode?
I'm not sure if I like Soloist mode for Alter.
It feels like... harder.
Definitely...
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh.
Oh!
What?!
I... What happened?!
What the f... I...
Oh, I get to go again?
Okay.
What the f... happened?!
I don't even... I don't even know what happened!
I can't tell!
What the f... just happened to me?
It happened so fast!
Am I gonna die here?
It's fine.
Okay.
I see somebody over there.
Alright, that's my death location.
I was there.
That's f-ing right?
It's fine.
Another team is shooting him.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
What the f... I see you there.
Okay, why is everyone...
Why is everybody coming to me?
This place is like no man's land.
Oh, I see you in that smoke.
I see you.
There you go.
I saved your life.
Alright.
Oh, f-!
Oh, this isn't my life though!
Bro!
Bro, I saved your life!
Where's my payback?
Dude, I blinked and your health disappeared.
That is a good question.
What the f- happened to me?
What if I just go here?
Alright, there has to be a...
Oh, there he is.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Wait, how many lives do I have?
Oh, I get death recap!
Okay.
That was how many lives I have.
Guys, I figured out how many lives I have.
You get two lives.
Okay.
That's good.
The best part of solo is that you need to carry yourself down.
Thank you, SuperChacko.
Thank you, thank you.
I was totally carrying myself!
Those two wins I got...
I was not the... I was not the problem.
Those games that I won...
I was... I was a f-ing helper.
I was middle of the pack helping you.
You can requeue?
Yeah, I keep forgetting to requeue.
I was just so used to just going back to the menu.
Ezreal, thank you for the 10 gifted ships!
Thank you!
Friend, thank you for the Super Chat!
I blanked myself for a sec and you...
I blinded myself for a sec and you died.
What happened?
I won.
I didn't die.
You see, the great thing about blind people is that you can lie to them.
Because they can't see.
But I didn't lie to you friend.
Of course.
I would never lie to you.
That was not a lie.
Just so you know.
Who has a better trade-off?
The PK and the alternator?
Bro!
That's not
right!
What?
That's messed up.
Don't worry.
Not just blind people.
It works with deaf people too.
That's funny.
I didn't lie though.
Not this time.
Okay.
I have an enemy near me.
This is so fucked up.
How come I get the charge?
Where are my benefits?
Oh!
And then he gets the fucking...
What was that?
Is that spitfire?
Yeah.
Is that gray?
I won.
See?
I hear him.
He's like right over there.
Here he is.
I see him.
He's just looting.
Wait.
I hear more than one.
Bro!
Fucking let me breathe!
Fuck this.
You guys fight each other.
I'm going out of this portal.
I'm going out of here.
You guys fight each other.
What?
You fucker!
You actual fucker.
Bro.
There's literally people right here.
I can't believe it.
You chased me all the way here!
Where's the other guy?
What?
There's literally one other guy here!
And he disappeared.
Is he also blind?
Gator, thank you.
Thank you.
How are you going to say that about blind people?
Doki.
I told my friend what you said and he typed.
It was personal.
I got a hug.
I'm the only reason why.
Dude.
Okay.
I'm going to say it.
This character sucks for solos.
Lance.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Dude.
I blinked.
Doki.
I blinked and you were running away.
What happened?
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
What I'm saying is that I picked the wrong legend.
For this.
I picked the wrong legend for a solo's mode.
This is definitely not a solo's character.
At least I had a conduit shield.
It's like extra shield.
What do you mean?
Replicator coming down.
I don't know actually.
I'm trying to think what would be a good solo character.
I guess like Bangalore.
Bangalore or maybe Bangalore Wraith Pathliner.
Just for the mobility.
I feel like Alter is definitely a team character.
Okay.
There we go.
We got it.
We got Wingy and the Prowler.
That is an improvement from a charged fucking rifle.
Definitely a huge improvement.
Oh my gosh.
I hear so many shooting.
Ooh.
Okay.
Wait.
Actually...
We'll go with this for now.
Actually no.
We'll go with this.
I don't want to run double.
I don't want to run double heavy.
Alright.
Let's go.
Ginger, thank you for superchatting and thank you!
I think you dropped this.
Oh my god!
Thank you for returning my $20 Ginger.
I really appreciate it.
It's crazy.
I dropped so many cash today.
It's actually...
Okay.
Am I getting shot by two people?
Why am I always getting shot by two?
Please!
Why can't you get shot by two people?
Oh my god, bro, I dropped so much money everywhere.
It's like literally everywhere.
Guys, can you help me find my money?
I'm so sorry.
Bro, okay, I swear if it's this guy, I'm fucking gonna try and...
That's fucking right.
Run!
Run, you bitch!
You seem like a guy that fucking shoots people in the backs.
There you go.
Oh, fucking hell, I'm so mad.
Finally, I got an actual 1v1.
Let's see.
I finally got my own 1v1 and I won it.
I told you it wasn't me!
I kept getting shot in my back!
It's you.
That's right, it's not fun, right?
It's not fun getting shot in the back, right?
Wait, do I not have shields?
There he is.
No, no, no!
That's not fair!
I'm supposed to shoot people in the back!
Hey, I found a random here.
Says his blouse is yellow but also tomato, bird.
I wonder who that is.
Super, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, maybe...
Okay, not a solo play... not a solo character.
Alright, fuck this.
Wait, not... wait, what?
I picked Bangalore...
Oh, wait, what?
That was so weird.
Guys, thank you for finding my money, guys.
I'm returning it back here.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The crutch character.
Is this yours, ma'am?
It was stuck in the blind person's pocket.
Mr. Broken butt.
Thank you for the akka super.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, thank you everybody for finding my lost money.
A fucking gorse from the person you least expected.
A blind person.
Bro...
Oh my god, thank you everybody for finding my lost cash.
Hey, I saw you dropped this but why do you have British currency?
You know, I just like to collect money every so often, you know?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Leon.
I just like to collect.
It's like collecting coins except like money.
This time, this time will be different.
Blind people being put on blast.
Hey, hey!
It's not just blind people but also deaf people.
Yes, collecting money.
Alright.
I fucking swear if you guys get a better gun than me, I swear to god.
Where is he?
There's two people here.
This is fucked up.
Oh, he ran away.
He took a zip.
Okay, thank god.
One enemy nearby.
I hear him.
Please make this an actual 1v1.
That's all I ask for.
For BoBat.
Oh my god.
But you're worse.
You're actually worse.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Poor guy.
This is it.
A proper 1v1.
They've told me about this.
No, that's not a proper 1v1 anymore.
I saw him running over.
Yeah.
I saw.
I was like...
Oh my god.
It's not a proper 1v1 again.
Come on.
Wanna chill?
You fucker.
You fucker!
You came back!
He came back!
You bitch!
Why?
You want to have a proper 1v1?
It's the same.
He came back for revenge!
Bro, okay.
Bro, fuck this two lives bullshit.
It should be one life.
Like, it should be one life.
Because they get to play like a fucking pussy.
Like, this shit sucks!
This is bullshit!
They come back for revenge!
Just like what I'm about to do.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is he?
There's no way I'm the last third party here.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my god.
They actually came back.
I... Bro!
This fuck sucks!
Like...
Like every time!
Every time I shoot one...
Every time I shoot one shot, I get shot in the back.
Get out of the way.
This... Bro!
This keyboard fucking sucks!
Everyone should have one life.
Like, it's just cause they'll come back!
They keep coming back!
That's just bad luck.
Everyone... Yes, but I don't think... Okay, I'll show you guys how having Bloodhound would not change anything.
It will not change anything.
People will still fuck me over.
Always expect a third party.
Bro, it's like non-stop!
That's the worst part!
Bro!
Like...
They're shooting me in the back!
The dead should stay dead!
The dead should stay fucking dead!
Like, what is this bullshit?
They keep coming back!
And shooting me in the fucking back!
I'll be back.
Okay, there's three people here.
Surely those two will fucking shoot each other.
Right?
Oh my god.
Let me land in the middle of these guys.
Surely... I fucked up a little.
Okay.
I'll be in here now.
I'm gonna live underneath you.
Wait, I could go here.
Bye.
Wait, he's gone.
Okay.
It's not that bad right now.
Okay, they're shooting each other.
They're shooting each other.
That's good.
That's so good.
Wait, okay.
I got a plan.
Wait, this is a good plan!
This plan is brilliant!
You can't third party me if I shoot from the distance!
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright, this is it.
I'll just stop.
Shit!
I'll just stop pushing people.
I'll just stay here.
I'll just fucking stay here.
Listen, we discovered the play.
This is how we gotta play this.
If I just stay here.
Don't push up.
Don't push up!
I have a sniper!
Oh god.
Oh god, he came back for revenge.
Don't push up!
I have a sniper!
Where are they coming from?!
There's no way he pushed up, right?
There's no way.
Why are they all coming to me?
Guys.
Guys, look.
I'm... I'm...
There we go.
Oh my god!
He had the same plan!
That's illegal!
That was my plan!
How can he have the same plan as me?!
I don't... How did he have... What?!
He also has the same plan!
Why are they all sniping?!
Bro!
They're all stealing my ideas!
This is so fucked up.
They all stole my idea.
Like, I had this idea first.
Now everyone is sniping.
I had... I had this idea first!
Why are they all stealing from me?
Oh wait, wrong one.
It's okay, I'm better.
No!
He's so low!
He was so low.
I cracked one of them.
No!
Wait!
Fuck off!
I'm trying to snipe!
This is so messed up.
I can't believe my ideas got stolen.
This is how...
This is how my hero felt like.
Like...
Thomas Edison.
This is how my hero felt.
Where is he?
Oh, he DC'd.
Nice.
Thank god.
Should've batted him first.
Is this the same guy?
It is.
Same guy that got shit on.
Dude, the main is a sheep snake.
Let's go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Keep complaining about them.
Is he gonna peek me again?
For stealing my fucking ideas?
That's...
That has to be a Tesla stat.
Stealing ideas that are rightfully mine.
Tesla dude got shit on twice.
He got shit on and fucking ran away like a little bitch.
Alright.
Okay, let's see.
He's still sniping!
I literally saw him fucking sniping from 20 miles away.
Look at him!
He's still doing it!
This is 180.
Oh, he's like running away from me too.
That's the funny part.
I can't believe this is solo mode.
This is the longest I've ever lived.
Just cause I'm playing sniper.
This is actually the longest I've ever lived.
This is so sad.
Where am I gonna shop from?
I wonder where the Mirage guy is.
I can't believe this Mirage guy has so many shields.
That's like the craziest part for me.
How does he still have the shields for this?
No.
Oh, no.
You don't get to fuck me over here like this.
That's fucking right.
I'm a better sniper.
hahaha hahaha hahaha hahaha hahaha I'm a better sniper.
Bro, everybody here is just sniping!
Bro!
What?
Why?
This is my area!
Leave!
Literally everybody here is sniping!
Actually, leave me alone!
I don't have shields anymore!
Oh my gosh!
Like, leave me alone!
You started this, Doki!
I didn't think everyone was gonna snipe!
I literally have zero shields.
Like, I'm just...
How did these guys have the shields for this?
Are you serious?
People are in my home!
Oh my god.
People are...
Bro, fuck off!
I have one... I'm leaving... fuck this area.
I'm actually leaving this area, bro.
Fuck this place.
I'm tired of fucking fighting.
It's actually so dumb.
Like, I'm actually so tired of fighting there.
Like... Oh my god!
Everybody's there!
That's like the worst part!
I like, need loot!
Like, I forgot I still have two more lives... like, one more life.
Oh my god, I can finally live in peace.
Fucking finally.
After being harassed for so long in that one area.
But what if you... Bro, fuck that shit, bro!
I'm not going back there!
I got fucking harassed for so long that I couldn't leave!
Like, I legitimately was stuck there for 20 years, I feel like.
I've been tapped.
This is the longest I've been alive.
You know what?
You're right.
Maybe I should...
Oh wait, he has a home there.
Hey, but let me... Please, let me have my loot at least.
Okay, I just want shield cells.
I don't want anything else.
Just give me those shield cells.
God, it's a strafe!
It's a strafe!
I swear!
I swear, the strafe is fucking me up!
I wasn't whiffing.
The strafe was so uncanny.
I swear to god.
I wasn't up with...
It's strafes!
It's the strafe patterns!
Okay, I'm gonna grab this.
Maybe I can snipe with this.
Look, I lived for so long.
Don't fucking see.
With.
This is the longest I've lived in this game.
Oh my god.
This is hell.
I feel like solo mode is literally just sniping.
This is not fun.
I mean, I guess you can practice sniping, but still.
This shit is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
This is the game mode now.
This is solo mode.
Are you fucking... Bro, please.
Please.
You and I both have to go to zone.
You have to come down, sir.
You're not in zone.
That's fucking right.
He's so confused.
Oh, fucking hell.
This is not fair.
This is not fair!
Are you serious?
No!
Fuck off!
Bro!
Where did the Bangalore go?
Where the fuck is the Bangalore?
I need to die.
Snipe took you.
But I really give it.
But no, fuck this game.
This game fucking sucks.
Fuck this game.
It's either third party or sniping.
That's it.
It really is.
Open the season.
Good job on the sniper battle.
I swear.
Not gonna lie.
I liked it.
Until...
Until you get sniped by 20 people.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Then we'll see how much you like it.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Fuck it, I'll go call on you.
I'll go call on you.
I won't steal people's characters anymore.
Oh my god.
It's fucking a bullshit.
It actually is.
Actually so fucking bullshit.
It's not fair.
It's not fair at all.
As an introvert Apex player, I like this game mode.
As a fucking M you like this game mode.
Bro I still can't believe that one area landed on and everybody was just sniping each other.
They're from each building.
Each building just had its own sniper.
Alright, here you go.
It's not fair because they always come back!
Because when you kill them, they're gonna come back and shoot you in the back.
And they always arrive when I'm in a fight.
They always arrive when I'm in a fight.
That's the worst part.
That actually is the worst part.
They don't wait until, you know, to do a respectable 1v1.
They're like, no, I'm gonna fuck this person so hard.
Get her out of that lobby.
Fuck her, I hate that bitch.
A lot of people are using Mozambique.
Is it good now?
Is there anybody here?
I don't think anybody's here.
I mean...
I don't think anybody's landing here.
He's so awesome.
There's so many people running Mozambique.
Is it good or not?
By now.
I don't think so.
Because none of this is loot...
Oh, wait, wait, wait!
JK.
There's a Caustic here.
On me?
Okay.
Whoa.
No!
He's one!
Please!
Please, he's one!
Do the right thing!
And clutch!
There you go, he did it.
He did the right thing, guys!
No, that's one guy.
No, he just knocked one person out.
I'm Res me.
I'm so Res-able.
Guys, look at me.
This is what you get.
He was literally one HP.
This is what you fucking get.
Fucking please.
Where's our third?
Oh my god, where are you?
Save this man!
He's literally right here!
He's on my door!
He wants to mess me up!
He's right here!
Oh no, he doesn't.
He's just running.
I think he's gonna lose this.
He's definitely gonna lose this 1v1.
There's no way he wins this.
There's no way.
There's no way he wins.
Okay.
I fucking knew it.
There's actually no way he wins this.
All I'm saying is that if he-if that man was there with us...
I got my 1.
I got my 1v1.
I don't know about you, but I got my 1.
It's always my team.
It's never me.
Always remember that, Dokie.
Every time you die, it's never your fault.
You're gonna be the new coach for TSM?
Okay, first off, we gotta-we gotta have a team first.
It doesn't seem like there's going to be a TSM team at the moment.
That's actually crazy, though.
That's actually crazy.
Like, cause like, TSM has been like a team together for so long.
Too soon!
Damn!
Please, let me play ulti!
I just wanna play ulti!
Oh, sorry.
I upped the game volume a little bit, so I don't know.
Uh...
Let me tell my sound guy.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
I don't know if it's like too loud or-now or like if it's better now.
Introducing your champion.
TSM made this ban only-yeah.
There's rumors that TSM-oh my god, that's such a cute banner!
Wait, that's such a cute banner!
Uh, there's rumors that TSM made this ban.
And I feel like-I feel like-I feel like it might actually happen.
Because those tweets-those tweets from reps and bros is so sus.
Like, why would they tweet that?
Only in Apex, yeah.
It's just Apex.
Apex rumors.
They landed on me?
No they haven't.
I'm okay.
Okay.
Alright, 9, Havoc.
And then, got my guns.
Got what I need.
Let's fight!
Surely I won't get plucked over here, right?
Nope.
I knew it.
I knew I'd be okay.
Alright, Havoc.
Really?
Where?
Wooo!
I'm gonna stand here.
I don't think they know I'm here now.
If they know I'm here, they're stream sniping.
What the fuck was that?
Wait, how do I get back though?
Oh, that's how.
Oh, that spray was not-oh!
Okay, that's fine.
That was not a good-WOOOOO!
That's not fine!
Wooo!
That was-that was not-I'm okay now.
Okay, we got a little merry-go-round.
It's okay, we're fine.
See, I told you we're fine!
Nothing to worry about.
Alright, we're gonna...
That R9 was not attractive right there.
I need to get rid of this.
Okay.
Let's see...
Calculate-it was so calculated.
Of course it was!
Of course it was calculated.
I'm a gamer!
Oh, wait, alternator.
Oh, wait, no, they already used the disruptor.
Alright, we're fine.
We're so okay.
Let's see...
I really wanna try-wait, we have hammerpoint, right?
Wait, actually...
I remember I saw a hammerpoint back there.
I'm gonna grab it.
Is R9 even good?
No, but I'm, like, coping.
At the moment.
It's not.
I'm just...
I'm just going through nostalgia with the R9.
That's why I got the...
That's why I got the vault.
Alright.
Back to the old days.
Bring me back.
Give me my nostalgia bait.
Please, I don't have anything else.
Let's see...
Care package over there.
Let's just go somewhere, guys.
Let's leave.
There's clearly no other teams here.
Yay!
I'm just gonna go straight.
I'm just gonna go straight here.
And also grab the armor.
There's no way I get shot in the air, right?
There's no way I land into three teams.
Like, my bad luck is not that bad.
Give me season...
Okay, we're not going that further back, bro.
We're going back, but that's way...
You went too far.
That's a bit too far, bro.
I heard, like, shots here.
Let's see.
On me?
The fuck is this?
Are they, like, rapping?
Like, what is that?
Pop, pop.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, there is a chance that my bad luck is that bad.
It's me, me.
Hahaha.
I'm putting off all the defenses right now.
Are you serious?
They were, in fact, serious.
Oh, wait.
I helped.
Oh, God.
I did it!
Oh, my God!
You're welcome.
You're absolutely welcome.
I feel like I deserve all that loot for everything I did.
Okay, I heard, like, shots from here.
There they are.
Okay, I forgot I'm climbing up this.
Holy shit, I did it, guys!
I clutched.
I assisted.
Watch this.
Did you watch it?
Hahaha!
I told you to watch this.
Oh, fuck, don't watch.
Did you watch it, though?
I got my one.
Did you watch it?
I got my one, guys.
Okay, we are going to get rid of the hammerpoint moves.
We are gonna get rid of the hammerpoint moves.
I realized we're at more...
Guys, I realized like...
My place.
Guys, no, no, no.
I didn't panic.
I didn't panic because I got my ones.
I got my ones.
Wait, what the fuck?
It disappeared.
Wait, that's so cool.
Wait, what?
How did he get over there?
Holy shit, what?
Oh my god, you can do that?
Because I think he knows how to... Oh, was that... No, that's not an ult.
Was that the ult?
No way, that can't be the ult.
Because I saw the portal.
I thought that was his Q.
Oh, it was?
Okay, I thought that was the Q.
I was like so surprised.
Like, what the fuck?
Alright.
I was like, there's no way he travels that far.
Oh my god, I'm fucking holding too many syringes.
Doink.
Let me grab this for everybody because I'm a team player.
Yay!
Where the fuck are the rest of the teams?
Guys, I need to break 1k.
Guys, I fucked up a lot.
Whoa, why am I so fast?
That arrow made me so fast.
My momentum was crazy there.
Let's see, we need that.
Uh...
Anything for me?
Yoink.
Where is the team?
Okay, we have to go back.
This is not even in the...
No, it wasn't my passive though.
That's the thing.
Because everybody was close by.
Everyone was so close to me.
It can't be my passive.
I think it's the momentum of the stairs.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
The momentum of the stairs made me so fast.
Yeah, it's the stairs.
The stairs actually made me go zoom.
Whoa!
Don't worry!
You're okay!
Wait, where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
They have to come here, right?
There's no way that hits me.
I told you, there's no way that hits me.
No way this hits me too.
I have the high ground.
Push in!
Come on, push in!
Oh, we should be able to push in now with this.
Oh, God.
Alright.
Okay, goodbye!
Not the dead zone!
Oh, no!
The fucking dead slide!
No!
Oh, my God.
I can't believe I got dead slid so hard.
I got my one.
All I'm saying, I got my one.
Where the fuck were there one?
Not the slide.
Oh, no!
My dead slide!
It fucked up my slide.
It fucked everything up!
Everything went...
That could...
Oh, my God.
This guy is a fucking top 17 Pred.
Bro, what are you doing?
Don't you want Pred again?
Bro, don't you want...
The dead slide!
No!
I told you it's not me.
It's the game.
The game's sabotaging me.
It's sabotaging me.
Oh, my God.
He talks.
I guess any gun.
They're talking to each other.
They're letting each other know what guns they want.
What's a dead slide?
It's like when you try to slide for momentum, but you don't get the momentum.
That's what it is.
That's the dead slide.
He speaks.
He has a mouth.
Isn't that crazy?
Oh, my God.
A fucking mouth.
Holy shit.
That's insane.
Alright.
Please!
I just wanna play Alter!
Give me Alter!
That's right, you don't even get Conduit.
If I can't get Alter, you can't get Conduit.
Number three.
Hahaha.
Yeah, it's the slide, but you don't get the actual slide part.
It's pretty sad.
I shouldn't have communicated.
Look.
You can tell I get worse every season because...
What?
Wait, this is a three...
This is a three man fucking pred team!
You see, I like my... like...
Every season, I get worse because my badges get lower.
Alright, here we go.
Where's my pred players?
Where are they?
Where are my pred players?
JinJin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is what happens when you get older?
That is not true.
That's a fucking lie.
VTubers don't age.
We're digital.
We can't age.
How dare you?
You're fucking kidding here, bro.
Alright, I should go to... my teammate.
Oh shit.
No way he sees me, right?
Told you he doesn't see me.
Oh, bloody ass teammates!
Guys!
Oh
my...
Wait, there's night...
Okay, guys.
Okay, I fucked up.
There's another team.
Guys, don't come over here.
Everywhere I go, people die.
And by people, I mean me.
Oh, you bitch.
You bitch, you have nothing in your life.
Why are you thirsting?
It's okay, I'll slowly crawl... I'm so safe.
I'm so safe.
I'm so fucking safe.
Ignore that guy shooting at you.
Ignore that one guy that shot you.
I'm so safe.
Okay, now that you shot his friend, he might shoot me.
There's another team there!
Oh my... okay.
Okay, he might shoot me because you shot his friend.
Alright, I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm so safe.
I am not safe, but like, just pretend I am.
He's really waiting for me there.
Oh god.
Surely he can't see that.
He's really waiting for me there.
Oh god.
I did it.
Are you kidding, bro?
Me too, bro!
I don't have med kits!
Oh, no!
Okay, I have no ammo.
Oh my god, I actually have nothing.
I have nothing right now.
Got it, got it.
All I have is my fucking repeater.
Call over, she can fuck off.
Okay, I thirsted one guy.
I'm gonna loot this.
Here's a med kit.
I'm gonna drop a med kit.
I have a med kit.
Nice.
I'm okay.
I helped.
I'm a team player.
Never forget.
Never back down.
Okay, I'm gonna fucking...
There's a full team right here on my ping.
I'm gonna grab this.
I don't have the ammo for this.
No, you're not.
No, you're not!
Get out of there, John.
Get out of there.
That was a no-brake!
I can't get out!
I'm getting shot from under two.
I've got the core.
Oh!
Where do you go from here?
Where do we go from here?
Oh my god!
He's one.
He's actually one.
He's so low!
He's right there still.
Jump to the left.
He's right here.
He's fucking hot.
Wait!
That's...
Fuck!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
There's another team here.
Bro, what the fuck is this?
Bro, chill!
Please!
It's like TDM, bro.
Oh my god!
First
time.
Gucci liquor.
Oh, this is where I die.
What is that?!
Holy shit!
Don't worry, I'm here, bro.
Wait, what the fuck was that war?!
I never...
Is this... Is this IHOP happening?
What?
Oh my god!
I can't possibly know why I'm here right after I shot them.
It was valiant but deadly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you extremely.
Oh, how many birthdays she has in a year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's merely just cosmetics, guys.
It's really...
Bro, chill.
Oh my god.
That shit was actually crazy.
Holy fuck!
Oh my god.
It never stopped.
The fight... fighting never stopped.
I was getting shot from 20 different directions.
There were shots from angles I didn't know existed.
It was an online waffle house.
It was absolutely insane.
Bro, what the fuck?
Where's my fucking pred team?
Where's my second and third player who's also pred?
You can't get off Mr. Bone's wild ride.
That shit was so fucking wild.
I guess they all want to try out Broken Moon.
They don't want to go through the teams.
The pro teams.
Weeee!
Where are they landing?
Ohhhhhhh my...
Am I gonna get anything?
Alright, this is where I die, most likely.
Guys, this is exactly where I die.
WOOO!
Wooo!
I creature climbed.
Wooooo!
Haha.
No, it's him!
We had a connection!
You were in my team!
I wasn't the first to die.
Deathstalker was.
No mercy.
I thought we had something.
I thought we had something, man!
We were literally on a team to get there.
How could you?
How could you do this?
Oh my god, this was the Pred team anyway, so it doesn't matter.
My team was not gonna survive that.
You ditched him.
I can't believe it.
Did our fucking battle not meant anything?
It didn't mean anything to this person!
What the fuck?
I'm gonna leave this team!
We're gonna leave it in the middle of everybody.
Oh my god.
I was destined to die there.
I truly was destined to die there.
Alright, that one guy.
Okay, that's a little bit better than he was a little bit better.
Alright, here we go.
Oh man, I feel like this new game mode, this new season has made everybody fucking wild.
Everybody's shooting at everything.
Oh my god.
There's no peace at all.
Yay, I get to play Alter!
Yay!
Oh shit, wait, that's such a cool battle intro.
Doki, you should have ever... That's different!
It's called streamer privilege.
What content are they making when they're shooting people?
Think of it that way.
Peace was not an intro.
Exactly.
They're not making content.
I am!
Alright.
They're just having... fun?
What's this word you're saying?
Fun.
Alright.
Is that new streamer mode?
Yeah, it's new.
Alright, let's see.
Give me a gun.
Nice.
Give me another gun.
I don't ask for much, just two guns.
Okay.
This is my redemption arc.
JK, I'm not fucking running that.
What the fuck?
Where did I get shot from?
Oh, from here.
Watch this.
Oh!
I tried so hard.
Okay.
Alright, this is awkward.
That was a little awkward.
Okay, I get that armor swap.
Oh god.
Okay, we're fine.
No!
He used it against me!
Okay.
Okay, I fucked up because I pressed Q into two people.
That was like... that was my oopsie.
I used my walls into two people.
And I got instantly shot at.
That was so fucked up.
I'm still learning!
I'm still learning her abilities!
Okay!
Her abilities are hard to master!
Her abilities... Oh wait, her teammates left her too.
It's okay.
We have Clifford the big red dog and Sonic the blue hedgehog.
Surely nothing can go wrong.
Oh my god!
The crossover of a fucking century!
Sounds like a skill issue.
This is it.
This is the crossover we needed.
This is the crossover that will give us the win.
The strong duo.
Yes.
Like, with those names... with those names, this duo is unstoppable.
I knew it!
I knew Clifford would be a 4k 20 bomb.
At his size?
He could just... he could just squish them.
Oh my god.
He could just squish them with his sheer size.
A bird, a dog, and a hedgehog.
What could go wrong?
God, that's one hell of a powerful team.
Bro, he could kill 20 people with just one step.
Clifford the big red guy.
This has to be winnable.
Okay, actually I should not have peaced out because like, everybody lands here so I'm like a little scared.
Not gonna lie.
I'm a little fucking scared.
Alright.
Okay, into the hole I go.
The hole is the goal.
Three people sharing this one hole.
Seems ideal.
Surely nothing can go wrong when he does that.
See?
There we go.
Nothing went wrong.
If I can go back up.
Wait, how?
What?
I can but I just chose not to.
Guys, I just chose not to go up.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, on me.
He's on me.
Whoa.
Okay, that was a cool hit fire.
You gotta admit.
Nice.
Where's your teammate?
Where is your teammate?
Okay, we gotta get rid of...
I wanna use the triple take.
Okay.
Alright, so I don't have ammo for the triple take.
That's okay.
Choices and...
...lose shit.
No, I chose not to go that way.
Cause I wanted to flank.
It was all a choice.
My choices matter.
Where the fuck are... Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Alright, let's go.
Let's flag.
Here we go.
Come on, Sonic!
You got this!
You gotta go fast!
Is he gonna do the thing?
What is he...
He's trying to...
He's trying to go inside!
He's like, fine, I'll use the door.
Oh, shit!
I like how he's like, I guess I'll use the door.
This is another team.
Yeah, this is...
Oh, God.
I'm trying to cover.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, I got you!
I got you!
Cover me!
Cover me, Sonic!
Okay, nice.
The flank!
Sonic, but the flank!
Woah!
Okay, that was a good name.
Not gonna lie.
That's why you're not getting rezzed.
Because I need your loot.
Where is he?
Is he gonna melee him?
You'll be fine, right?
Oh.
I contributed.
Let's see, I need that.
I need like a Prowler, I feel like.
Where's his teammate?
Teammate!
I mean, there's a spray.
I see the spray.
There's no way he's gonna shoot me while I craft, right?
That'd be fucked up.
It's like how like...
Like, guys have like the bro code where you should never...
No nutshots ever.
And then this is like...
This is the girl code.
Never shoot somebody when they're crafting.
That's...
It's crazy.
It can be applied to...
It can be applied in any situation.
That's the girl code.
Or that way.
Okay.
Is that how it works?
Yeah.
Let's show us our loud under some rules.
That man is not a bro.
Who said that?
I always go, that's fucked up.
You're not a bro, bro.
Wow, girls are complicated.
I did it.
Look, I did it.
You saw that?
Zoinks, I killed him.
Damn.
You're never safe from a nutshot.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna grab this.
And then...
I'm helping.
I need like a fucking prowler.
I just...
Oh, no!
Oh, I can cancel.
Okay.
That was an accident.
Wait, what?
Where?
Oh, there.
There.
Don't worry, I can go in too!
Where am I?
Whoa, that's where I am.
I need your armor swap.
Nice.
Everything is going the way we planned it.
Where's his teammate?
Oh, there it is.
No, Clifford, go!
I knew I could always believe in Clifford.
Oh, thank God.
I need this Prowler.
There you go.
The greatest sign of trust is letting your bro hold you right now.
So how many nuts did you hold?
Is that true, bro?
Does he speak for all the other bros?
So like, you know like trust falls?
You know how people have like trust falls?
You guys have like trust nuts?
Is that what it's called?
Not true?
Yeah, bro.
Bro, what?
If you've never had your bro hold your nut, is he really your bro in the first place?
I don't understand.
I don't understand, bro.
Yeah, it's the trust bro.
All I'm saying...
All I'm saying, if he's your best friend, if he's your best bro, prove it with a trust nut.
I know, it's trust nut with a trust.
True homies have the perfect hands.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, you gotta know if he's a real bro.
Let me hold the nuts, bro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay, so it's like, you know how like people have like best man?
Is he really your best man if he has...
If he has...
I've trusted him...
With the nuts.
What the hell is a trust- It's when a bro like...
It's when a bro holds it tenderly.
It's when you trust them with everything you have.
Trust them with the future kids You know, bro...
Oh my god.
I was like duck hunting for that guy.
I literally was like...
That was fucked up.
I almost fucked it up there.
Bro, I can't shoot this guy.
There you go.
Holy shit.
Yeah, trust them with the potential kids.
Exactly.
If you had to ask what it is, you never had a real bro then.
I've seen bros hold the inner thighs, but...
Then you never had a real bro.
I'm sorry to say this.
Man.
I'm sorry to tell you this.
You've never had a real bro.
A real bro would not have to ask.
Also, they wouldn't have to ask.
Hey bro, wanna feel my blood?
That's all I'm saying.
Wait, last team?
Oh my god.
I knew it.
I knew this duo was unstoppable.
Bro, what is this comp?
Wait, I hear them.
They're like inside the... They're inside the big shield.
If that's your real definition of a real bro, I don't need it.
Bro.
You don't trust your bro.
You don't trust them.
How can you have a best man if you can't even trust him?
If you can't even trust him, what's the future children?
Wait, so girls holding each other... each girl's over each...
No, because women don't trust each other.
Hahahaha.
I'll share.
Alright.
I'm gonna mark you five over here.
Doki, stop.
This is so true and real.
Alright, we're going downstairs.
Alright.
Oh, wait, they're over there.
What the f...
That's a... That's a solo?
Please.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, we just walk here.
That was the game.
I knew.
I knew it.
I knew this team was it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I had this team.
This team was it.
Oh god, please.
Okay.
I knew it.
Clifford the big red dog and Sonic the blue hedgehog.
That was easy effortless shit.
I know, right?
I trust my bros.
I just...
I don't wanna win anymore.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can't trust your nuts with me bro.
For your future bro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I knew it.
No!
My fucking bros!
Doki the big yellow bird.
There you go.
I can't believe it.
The most effortless game I had and all I did was contact.
Truly the game of all time.
Bro, it's over.
Okay.
Oh wait, they won too!
They all won.
They also won!
But their names are not as funny!
Are they truly winners if their names aren't even funny?
Is bro over?
Alright.
We're here.
We're ready.
Can't keep getting away with this.
Alright.
We're here.
We're here!
Yeah!
Looking for a new bro the last one.
I don't want a trust.
Mr. Toot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I'm pretty sure a dragoon here out there will do a trust... the trust nut with you.
I'm pretty sure.
Any dragoons that want to take his offer?
Alright.
Let's go.
Cookies, stop!
Oh shit!
It's fine.
Watch this.
They won't expect it.
Oh, fuck!
I didn't expect that!
I definitely didn't expect it.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, never mind.
I was gonna climb up and help him.
Boom.
Alright.
They did expect it.
Oh, shit.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
There's something surreal about hearing your Oshii talk about the trust net while following Sonic the blue hedgehog around!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
It's just... it's just...
It's just making sure, you know, you can trust your bro.
It's okay, he's fine.
He's so fine.
Wait, is this guy... that guy is Pred.
You fucking idiot.
Wait, what Pred are you?
Pred or Top what?
Oh my god, this guy threw garbage.
Now that's a distrust nut.
What I did there.
Alright, there's people over here.
Alright.
Different kind of trust!
Where did he get shot from?
Oh, yoink!
Oh, that's nothing to yoink from there.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
I'm going in.
JK.
Haha, JK.
They're all dead.
I'm gonna steal this real fast.
Oh, wait!
Watch this!
Oh!
That was scary.
Oh shit!
More people are coming.
There's people here.
I have to go up the old-fashioned way.
Give me a sec.
Send highlights.
I feel like that's cool.
Wait, below me?
What the fuck are they doing below me?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
What are they doing down there?
Nice.
See, we're winning!
We're doing it!
It's like a delivery!
Oh, this is so cool!
Wait, I actually like this ability a lot.
Actually, no.
Three and a 2x?
Yeah, that's fine.
Wait, who's shooting at?
Wait, what?
Oh, bro.
Bro, this is not good, bro.
Oh, no.
Bro, this is not good.
Never mind.
It's all good now.
Never mind, bro.
It's all good.
It's fine.
Watch this.
Where does this go?
Guys, I found out where it went.
Hey, guys.
I figured out where it went.
It was not a place I wanted to go, though.
Oh, no.
Bro, bro, bro, no!
Bro, no!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Where is he?
I'm looking.
What?
Trying to cover you?
I'm trying to cover you right now, bro?
Don't worry, bro.
I got you, bro.
I told you I got you, bro.
It's trust nut time.
Oh, I'm E.
Watch this.
Where?
Oh, shit!
Where am I?
Where am I going?
Bro, stop!
I trust it too hard.
Witnessed.
All right.
See?
We are winning now.
Harry, stop it.
You get lost.
I just... there's a lot of things going on!
You get lost too!
You have to go through what I went through!
There's so many things around me!
Guys, it's not a me issue.
It's an everybody issue.
You just don't understand.
You just didn't live through what I lived through.
I broke the net.
Thank you for the super chat, Dikowsing.
Thank you, thank you.
I literally clutched this for my team.
I clutched this.
You don't understand.
Wait, what?
Where are they shooting at?
Where do we go?
That's my first day, exactly.
This hero literally... this legend literally just got released, guys.
What do you want from me?
I'm learning it live!
I'm learning it live with all of you.
Let's see.
I mean, we could just...
Can we not put this out here?
We cannot?
That's bullshit.
Wait, we can.
That's actually bullshit.
I'm gonna put this here.
And then take this.
I leave.
I leave!
I leave now.
What?
Bro, we crossed paths!
We crossed streams!
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
We actually crossed streams.
Bro!
Bro, you like, fucked them up.
What happened?
Almost touched streams.
Bro!
That was like... out of nowhere.
I was like, who the fuck is that?
Alright.
Mine's a little red.
I think I might need to see a doctor.
Alright, mine's nexus no longer.
Alright.
That happened.
This is why you don't cross streams.
Oh, shit.
Well.
He's over there.
Whoa!
Yeah, I'm fucking going back.
Goodbye.
Yeah, that's a little bit too much.
Wow!
To put in your whole army!
Alright, there we go.
The entire army fucking came over to me.
Call in!
What the fuck?
Yeah, what's going on?
What the hell?
Is he behind?
Okay, that was very...
That was very ballsy of them.
Alright, nice.
That was actually so confident that... Holy shit.
I still have one more charge?
I do.
Wait, no, I don't.
Okay, let's see.
I'm gonna grab that.
Yeah!
Very ambitious.
Yeah.
Very fucking ambitious.
Those free kills.
Let's see.
If I had nickel every time Doki said, watch this, and I immediately jump scared, I could possibly play for the super chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Where's another team?
We gotta go this way, guys.
Guys, I just realized he's live!
Oh my god!
I feel these finesse.
Let's go.
Where do we go?
Oh, this is new.
I've went through this before?
To be fair, this map has been like blurring together for me.
Alright, let's see.
Down, not go!
Wait, I can just drop down.
Oh, it's like... this is like the storm point thing.
It's a trust fall again.
Okay, watch.
Nobody.
Okay, thank god.
Hahaha!
Every time I go through those portals, I just hope there's nobody there.
There's people here though.
On me.
What a nasty villain over here.
He's up here too.
Oh!
That was not supposed to happen, but I take those!
Wait, what?
Where are they?
I hear them.
Hey.
Back I go.
Yeah, they were up top.
No one there heard them.
Is he still up there?
There's no way.
Wait, what the fuck?
There's a crypto here.
Don't worry.
Surely he's not down here again.
Oh, he isn't.
No way, bro!
Got you!
Bro, I got you, bro!
Okay.
Nice.
Told you I got this, man.
Alright, I'll go this way.
Okay.
Let's see.
The last three squads are shooting at each other, I think.
Yeah, they are.
There's no way I could get fucked over here.
There you go.
There's no way.
There's no way they're just gonna shoot back at me.
They're too stupid for that.
The other team is like...
They were looking at another team on my right side.
Woo!
Okay, I just realized I don't have a lot of ammo.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
Surely it'll be okay, right?
Yeah, surely it'll be okay.
Me and my... Oh, wait!
I knew it.
I knew things would be okay.
Everything always looks up for me.
I knew it.
Wait, they have to drop down, right?
No, they don't.
Wait, can I like...
Go up from here?
Like, how fucked would I be?
Don't go up!
Woah!
Yeah, I'm not doing that again.
Who would've thought it'd be pretty bad?
Who would've thought it'd be pretty fucking bad?
Oh my god!
They... Wait, they have red armor!
Wait a minute.
How long have they been here?
Guys, stop.
Guys, I'm gonna come with you.
Do it again.
It'll be so funny.
Okay, but like, what if I do this?
Watch this.
What if I...
Okay, death 30.
30.
Oh no.
What if I...
Guys, it would be so funny though.
What...
Okay, let me actually contribute to this fight.
Okay, let me actually contribute.
We actually have to be part of this game now.
I think it's like one guy, not gonna lie.
I'm pretty sure.
But he just walked behind.
There's no way.
He literally just walked in the back.
But where is this other team?
Oh shit.
Come back.
Look, look, look.
I'm helping.
I'm covering.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, che!
Fucking che!
Wait, what?
I heard people.
Right behind us.
Oh god.
Give me a shot at it while I do this.
They're like right here.
What is he trying to do?
Waste our ammo?
Like, what is he trying to do?
Oh my god.
These guys are so annoying though.
They are so fucking annoying.
So annoying.
Holy shit.
Guys, fucking che!
Don't have a lot of shields.
Okay, I have zero shield cells left.
Okay.
Bro, how do you still have ammo?
Oh my god.
Bro, fuck off.
What the fucking...
The fucking jiggle peek from the crypto.
Are you serious?
The crypto has a goddamn jiggle peek.
That's actually so funny.
Fuck it, we'll put it here.
Alright, here we go.
There.
What a waste of a crypto.
Wait, what?
Okay, I'm gonna cover the left side just in case.
What was that?
Are you serious?
What a fucking move.
I'm gonna ult.
I'm gonna do this just in case.
Wait, are they dead?
Where are they?
Who ulted?
Wait, this is a rock.
HAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHAHA Okay.
You know, effort, effort.
I was gonna say, why would you ult that?
Oh no, he's down.
Where is he?
I fucked up.
Where?
Okay, I see him.
No!
This is... No!
Don't itembrace!
Please!
He's my teammate!
Bro!
He's so low!
He was actually so low, man!
Bro!
It's one guy!
One guy.
I don't let... don't let him rez.
Literally one guy.
Literally.
It's literally one guy!
We did so much!
Yes!
They left me alone.
Got the other.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
We did it.
We won.
Oh my god.
We fucking won.
Bro!
He almost got one guy!
He got me.
Oh my god.
We did it.
I did the most I can do.
See?
Middle of the pack.
Consistently.
Consistently averaged.
Look, we are consistently averaged.
Stop being scared.
Back to back.
Back to fucking back, guys.
She's so mid.
14 kills got... Bro!
That guy stole... is a kill stealer!
14 kills with 2.5k?
I had 4 kills with 2k!
That man is a kill stealer.
Bro, I don't wanna play... I don't wanna play fucking...
I don't wanna play ulti!
No one mid like Doki.
Bro, fuck this team.
I'm gonna leave this... Nah, you know what?
I'll let this team die.
My suffering!
Oh my god!
This guy's not having a good time.
Alright, we're gonna go full in.
I'm glad this is death.
Everybody will die here.
Shake my head.
My... oh, she is mid.
Alright... you stole alter.
I'm glad this to death.
We're all gonna die here.
Bro needs to block off.
We're getting all wins today.
Guys.
I wouldn't trust that.
Alright, here we go.
We're getting a lot of wins, which is nice.
Can you guys just sell me the key?
Thank you!
Thank you everybody!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
Oh, see?
There he goes.
Surely they'll be fine, right?
I should like... Wow!
Hey guys.
Oh, one guy left already.
That's what you get.
Oh, they both left.
Alright.
Finally I can leave as well.
This is a different game.
Nice.
Oh my god, I can feel the fucking R&D I'm getting there.
What's he gonna do?
Peek me right here?
Okay, yeah.
That's what he did.
How was I supposed to know that he knew I was there?
Now my pro and dozer not trust already.
How is that?
Oh, and they're running?
These cowards.
I wish they... These fucking cowards.
Not even two seconds.
Do you think he saw me guys?
I can't believe it.
They're fucking running?
In a pub?
What are you?
Can't believe it.
If I don't get ulti, I leave.
Oh.
I stay.
Yay!
Nice.
Yes, I stay.
I'm glad Doki is keeping to the script today.
Ulti or leave.
Exactly.
Ulti or leave!
Rad, welcome to the tomato farm!
I really love this banner.
It's so cute.
Thank you for the... Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
No.
I don't wanna be jump master.
Alright.
Ulti or troll.
Exactly.
Not nicely possessive.
Wait a minute!
She speaks Cantonese!
I speak Cantonese!
We are...
Good bros.
Top 10 quotes before disaster.
It's basically me!
Wait, what?
Oh shit!
Yeah, those are definitely enemies.
Oh!
Okay.
I did not expect them to...
Oh!
They locked her in!
That's so fucked up!
Holy shit!
Oh no!
That's so fucked up!
Oh my god!
I got shot by three different people.
Look at that!
They have to be squatted up.
Bro, there's no way.
There's no way that team is like not in a voice call right now.
That was so coordinated.
Okay!
But guys, that shit was incredibly coordinated.
That was actually crazy how coordinated they were.
Literally snared... fucking snared and locked us in.
And they said, get that bitch.
That was so fucking crazy.
That was like... and they literally... I'm pretty sure they did a countdown too.
It was 3, 2, 1.
Yeah!
No alter.
I leave.
Let me leave.
It's okay.
We'll let random.
They're giving you a... tell your trust nuts now.
Like, we wish your teammates are like this.
They prep this for a week.
Dude, I feel like they had a plan.
I leave.
That's fucking right.
Did they say something like, wait, this is a streamer?
And I left.
It's like a Wild West sighting.
Yeah.
It's like a...
It's like a Wild West sighting there.
Like, you see a Doki Bird.
Like, it's like bird watching.
You see Doki Bird for one second and then she's gone.
It was a legend.
The one second of Doki Bird before she disappears forever.
Oh my god, we're gonna third wheel this date!
We're gonna third wheel this date!
Little bird watching.
Bird seeing.
Oh shit, there's the... there's the roller player.
Oh, there's the roller player.
There's the roller player.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
It's okay.
Blimey.
Ask him about the Dresden.
They should have taken a picture before it.
It's okay.
I'm logged in into their bird watching book.
I'm in the log.
I'm the third wheel.
Take us here.
Okay.
It'll be a great date.
It's a life and death date.
Oh my god!
She took us there!
I mean, it ain't a real date until somebody might die.
I feel terrible.
At least they got rid of Promenade.
Alright, let's see.
We're gonna loot in the best kind of dates, exactly.
Is it really a date?
Unless the threat of death is looming over your heads.
Alright, let's see.
I got a Nemesis and a Wingman.
That's too long range at the same time.
Don't worry, I got you!
I got through the rock.
Don't worry, I got you, man!
I got you, bro!
I got one of them.
Of course, I'm getting chased.
No, you're not!
You literally ran into a diff- Oh shit!
All I'm saying is he did not get chased.
He definitely did not get chased.
I literally blocked him from getting the data set.
They're both dead.
I was looming all this team here.
I was running away and the first thing they do is like, oh, let me go face that.
I was just like, what do you mean you're getting chased?
I literally got two of them away from you.
Bro, that sucks, man.
Guys, is it... we're like... it's like... we're like the eavesdroppers too.
Like, we're that... we're the eye in the wall.
But not like the voyeuristic way.
Like, not the creepy voyeuristic way.
Because they know I'm here.
So they consented, I think.
I...
Again?!
Okay, I don't wanna...
Okay, I am... I don't wanna do it twice.
That sounds worse.
They know I'm here.
So it's not my fault if we're listening in.
You're...
4k people.
4k people watching Bro's Day.
Look, we're judging them.
Guys, I just don't wanna hear... don't wanna be in an awkward... awkward third wheel again.
Like, twi... okay, if there was like a little like... uh... intermission between it, that's fine.
But there wasn't.
I had to like listen in twice in a row.
Like...
Look, I wanna listen in on other people's stuff.
Awkward.
Okay, Mr. Rat.
Oh, no, no, no.
Please.
Please, I'm streaming.
I'll give you... $5.
No, I can't type fast enough!
I can't... I can't type fast enough!
No!
Let me play Ulti!
What if I leave this one too?
I just wanna leave... wanna play Ulti.
Let's go.
We need...
I'm sorry.
We need the other player...
Oh.
Okay, Ryan needs you so much.
Hello?
Oh, Vietnam, here we go.
Okay, this is the firstOH.
Hey.
I guess it bless you.
Loot.
Young!
Alright.
Death number two.
No ulti, then death.
We must go.
We got a lot of wins though today.
Just in case I need- Oh nice, they ran away.
That's even better.
Woo!
But it's such a waste though.
Wait, what?
You didn't run away?
Really?
You should have ran away, bitch.
Well, maybe I- Oh, you should have ran away, little boy.
That was the wrong thing you did.
Nice.
Yeah!
I leveled up!
Okay, I'm gonna heal real fast though.
Right in my mouth you go.
Gonna eat you up.
Oh, I'm gonna heal you up.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I need a- Oh, she has a podcast?
Where are they?
I'm a little scared that I don't know where they are.
I'll give you an amp first.
Wait, they're not- Who did I- Did I give nobody an amp?
Whoops.
That's awkward.
Oh great, I wasted it.
Oh, what?
Where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
Oh, there's another team here.
I know there is.
I'm too scared to go down.
Oh my god.
I knew I heard them.
They're right below us.
Mr. Rat, go in there, Mr. Rat.
That's fucking right.
But they didn't expect a second person.
Or the third!
Oh yeah?
I can go up there too.
That's fucking right.
Give me your money.
Give me your lunch money.
Bro, I'm trusting my bro.
Just giving my daily trust.
Alright, let's see.
Let's try the wing bang again.
Nice.
I'm locked in.
Five dollars for Doki.
JT, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I appreciate it, man.
Thank you so much.
Alright, let's get rid of these.
Surely.
Yeah, it's Trustnut.
I told you.
It's not toxic.
I'm trusting him.
Alright.
Let's see.
What's the...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I hear people.
They're like right here.
I hear the res.
The T in T-Bag stands for teamwork.
Exactly!
Somebody gets it!
I'm glad somebody gets it now.
Oh shit.
There's a fight.
Oh my god.
Pillow Princess.
You go, girl.
Watch this.
I'm gonna take it.
This is not Trustnut.
You see, you wait until they're done.
You wait until they res.
So like...
So you don't have to do anything at all.
That's my favorite part.
When you just wait for them to res.
So you don't actually have to do real work when it comes to fighting.
I'm gonna go.
Like right here.
I see them.
Where's my portal?
Where's my ult?
What the fuck?
Who is this guy?
Who the fuck is this random guy?
Okay.
I think I might accidentally need myself.
I have to make sure I don't accidentally need myself.
Where are they?
Wait.
Where did he res?
What the
fuck?
Okay.
I was gonna say.
I thought the guy that fucking jumped in was my own team.
Like... I was like, what the fuck?
Bro, I'm on your team, bro.
I was like...
I can't believe my team didn't fucking jump in with me.
That's fucked up, bro.
Sacrifice... I'm a conduit.
I should not be sacrificing my life.
I could have played backline, but I didn't.
Because I trusted my team.
So messed up.
Did I hear anything?
No, that wasn't it.
I heard something.
Oh, it's so messed up.
They like...
They went in there without...
Like I went in there and they didn't follow me up.
I have too many mid-kits.
Alright.
Let's go to zone.
Wait, I could grab... I'm gonna grab this armor and then I'll go to zone.
Yeah.
It wasn't...
It didn't like... reciprocate.
That... that...
You have to make sure you both reciprocate.
There really...
A railing here?
Nice, there is.
Nice.
Okay.
I noticed this isn't on the map anymore.
The railings.
Usually they're on the map, but they're not.
Or like this one wasn't.
Oh!
Who hit me?
Oh, he has red armor.
Oh, shit.
That's when you know they've been gaming.
Where are they?
Right there.
Let's see.
No!
Oh, shit.
Get closer!
Not that close!
I didn't mean you!
I meant the other lifeline.
I didn't mean this pathfinder.
There's a guy right here.
What the fuck?
Wait!
That's a different guy!
Oh, god.
Can I?
Please.
No!
I can't!
I made it!
Oh, my god!
Thank you.
What the fuck?
I made it!
Oh, my god.
I fucking made it.
Run!
That was close.
That was actually...
That was clutch.
That was a good ult.
What a...
My hero.
That was actually an incredible ult.
She saved my life.
So...
If you find our seats in your cheeks.
I did not expect her to actually help me.
That's insane!
All right.
Let's go.
Surely, we're not gonna let everybody know we're here, right?
Oh, weee!
Trust.
Told you!
In the trust bag.
I knew it existed.
I'm gonna grab this too.
I want a red armor.
Alright, we're in zone!
I need to craft a bat for wasting my bats there earlier.
Yeah!
Alright.
Got my bat.
That was actually crazy though.
The fucking...
The fucking ult actually saved my life.
Because I'm pretty sure those are two teams.
There had to be two teams.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way it was not two teams.
Where could they be?
Oh, care package.
What's in it?
What's in the care package?
Sir, look up!
Look up, sir!
Look up and tell me what's in the package!
Please!
All you have to do is...
Just look up!
I'm gonna...
Please, rat!
Mr. Rat!
That's all you have to do!
Just look up!
That's all I want!
Oh, okay.
There we go.
He looked up, guys.
It only took him 20 years.
But he finally did it.
He accomplished something that no man has ever done before.
Looking up.
Okay, that was a sick shot from how far I was looking at.
That should be a...
Oh, I thought that would be like a...
A armor upgrade.
Where is he?
Get shit on.
Get shit on!
Alright.
Gamers don't look up.
He accomplished something new today.
Is there an angle here?
I do.
Aw, that would've been so cool if I hit that, like...
Over there.
Let's see.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit!
Mr. Rat!
The world got you!
It's so like...
You can't crawl up.
Nice.
I just didn't want them to crawl up.
Oh, wait!
There's another fight here too!
Wait, I wanna fight this guy as well.
They're like...
So far away from each other.
And there's the lifeline as well.
Wait, the lifeline team won?
Oh my god, it's the goddamn triple...
Bro, fuck off!
It's the goddamn triple take lifeline!
I'm trying to like, figure out where like...
There we go.
Yeah, fuck you.
Thanks for the red armor, loser.
Oh shit!
Wow!
Let me in.
Wait, is he gonna shot at now?
Okay, that was a little fucking scary.
Oh, he's gonna go to the zone?
Alright.
I can deal with that.
I just have better...
I just have high ground, you know?
I love high ground here.
Wait, are we fighting?
What are we doing?
What's the decision, Mr. Rat?
Let me in.
I feel like this person actually knows how to play...
Ultra more than me.
Not sure.
My portals are just Hail Marys.
It's just like, will this work?
Those are...
Those are my...
Whoa!
Shit!
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Yes I...
Yes I leave.
Yes I leave...
Well...
Yes I leave.
Bye.
Alright, here you go.
Yeah, her portals are for some reason 100% better than mine.
I don't know how...
How she does it.
For some very odd reason, they really know how to portal.
I want them to push into the other team.
Bro, stop!
Stop!
They're running at each other!
Wait, we should run at each other!
They're running!
Let's go!
They're not running at each other anymore.
Okay, I'll take this.
What the fuck?
He's so fast!
Did you see that?
Bro, he's...
I cracked him.
He was so fucking fast, man.
I got him.
I don't want him to get rezzed.
Okay.
What?
Oh my god, he helped!
Guys, please!
Please don't lose this!
Please don't lose...
No!
They're gonna rezz!
Where's my team?
No!
Rezz!
Guys, no!
No!
This is a wrap!
Where was my team?
No!
Bro!
If we rush them, we win!
I literally got a knock!
I got a knock for us!
No!
I got...
I can't believe it!
Bro, it's over!
This is why if I don't get ulti, it's over.
I got a knock and everything!
I did so much damage!
I did so much...
Where was my team?
Look, all I'm saying was I did my part.
I did my part of this game.
Okay, we'll do one more.
We'll do one more Trios and one more solo.
It was so winnable.
It was so fucking winnable.
I fucking...
She didn't trust.
Yeah, I held my hand out.
I don't understand!
Oh my god.
Okay.
My fucking bow check aim was fucking crazy.
I was actually going nuclear there with my bow check.
I can't believe it.
How could they do this to me?
Okay.
This is it.
Your team waste- I know!
They wasted my effort!
Okay, my favorite part was the fucking guy that was zooming though.
The fucking ulti.
That just fucking zoomed as they crawled to their fucking death.
I know!
How could they not trust me?
Like, this is the face of somebody that's trustworthy and wouldn't let you die.
Okay.
We got a flatline.
Oh my gosh, I haven't used flatline in so long.
Let's see.
Okay.
Nice, I needed the holo on the flatty.
Ehhh.
I don't like it on this.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh shit!
Creepy slave, don't worry!
I got you!
Trust.
See?
I hit one shot out of four.
Oh my god, wait.
He needs help.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
I don't know where this is gonna go.
There.
I told you!
Trust!
Nice.
We did it.
Easy.
Fucking easy.
It's all about the trust, baby.
Okay.
Extend highlights, reduce alt.
I don't think I need the alt.
I like the health thing more.
I did it.
Excuse me, I have one kill.
I got my one.
Let's see.
Uh... You know what?
I wanna do more wingy.
Surely I'll eventually hit those shots.
Surely.
I believe.
It's all about believing in myself too.
I trust myself as well.
Alright.
Wait, they're all taking the rail.
Let me... Let me on.
Let me on the rail.
I wanna get on the ride.
I wanna get on the crazy ride.
It's all about coping.
I'll hit.
Might hit.
Okay, look.
I hit at least one shot.
And that's more... more than...
That's more than shot.
All I'm saying...
Alright.
Let's see.
Woo!
Woah!
Hold on!
That's all I'm saying.
I don't know.
Wait, people died here.
So I can steal this loot.
Yoink.
Oh my god!
Look at all this free loot!
Wait, this is amazing.
Yoink.
Where?
Oh, there!
Okay, let me bring out the other gun.
Let me bring... Let me bring out the gun that I...
That I can actually hit.
Okay.
There we go.
Yay.
Look.
I still hit those.
I still hit it, guys.
Shit, I actually tabbed out.
We've all been there before.
Okay, nice.
I should craft the bat.
Yay.
Anything else I haven't looted yet?
Oh, what the fuck?
I should...
Woah!
Wait, I don't like that.
That's funny.
It like fucking spat out a battery in front of me.
Let's see.
That's enough.
You guys think I have too many bats?
No, right?
Nah.
I should grab a sniper too.
Alright, here we go.
Oh shit, don't worry.
I'm here.
I'm gonna put this... here.
It's alright.
We can fall back if we need to.
I believe.
I feel like we don't need that many.
Okay, I definitely need more shield cells though.
Where?
There?
Haha!
Even Octane was like, what the...
Even Octane was like, hmm...
Oh my god.
Oh, he's so low.
Oh my god, he's so low too.
Oh god, the last guy is on me.
Oh god.
He's not gonna look at me, right?
Bro, I'm so confused!
He's like, where the fuck did this go?
And he was like, what the fuck?
And I hear him.
What?!
Oh, he was on me this entire time.
Wait, this is a different guy!
He wasn't on me this entire time!
He was a new guy!
There, he's dead.
There you go.
I had to think for a little bit.
There you go, we're fine.
I gotta think, but it's okay.
That is so cool.
See?
We did it.
We fucking did it, guys!
We're a team!
Yay!
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of...
It's not that I don't believe in myself.
It's that like...
Guys, it's not about a lack of belief at the moment.
It's just that I think it'd be better if I use this gun instead.
Just a little better.
I totally believe in myself.
Okay.
Let's see.
Is there like a 3x?
Oh, there is.
Oh.
Whoops.
I got rid of my 2x.
Okay.
No!
I got rid of my 2x!
I forgot!
Fuck off!
It's so far away!
Doki's cooldown on Wingman...
Yeah, I like used up my Wingman cooldown, guys.
It's so unfortunate.
It's so unfortunate, guys.
Let's see.
Oh, this way.
Whee!
Back.
Yay!
This game is so easy.
Do I need to craft a bat?
No, I have six bats.
We're fine.
I need 2x though.
I need 2x for this.
Or... I'd like flatline on 2x because I feel like...
It's just better.
It's a better... better scope.
Oh.
Where are they?
They're right here?!
Oh my god!
They're just chilling!
Oh, it's two guys!
But it's two guys.
Whoa!
I'm so fast!
It's literally two.
Instead of one guy, we get two guys.
Wooo!
No shield is gonna protect you.
Alright, this is it.
Oh, they saw us too!
They'll do an A-no.
They know it's a 3v2 now.
They fucking know.
Oh, is he looking at me?
Wait, does this guy have a 2x?
No.
No 2x.
Wait, I hear him.
He's over there.
Holy
shit!
Oh my god!
Oh, fuck!
Okay!
Don't look at me!
It's okay, we did it.
Oh my god, that was scary.
There's no way he dies.
Oh my god, they looked at me.
Yay!
We did it!
Yeah!
So easy.
The donking traction.
Look at me, I'm so scared.
No door can stop me.
They thought I would take...
Oh my god, none of us broke 1k.
That is so sad.
None of us!
We have like a predilection.
None of us broke 1k.
I like how I could have used the door, but I didn't.
I was just like...
They'll never expect it!
They never expect it, guys.
They are all looking at the door, thinking I'd pop up.
But I wasn't using the door!
Always ready to pop up a door!
Yeah, I'm going to use the door.
Oh my god, it's so cute.
So cute.
Solo mode, where all dreams die.
Yeah, doors are for poor people!
I bought the DLC.
I don't need to use doors anymore.
Alright, here we go.
Last game.
This might be a really fast game.
Honestly, this could be a very fast game.
Nobody to fight for Altaire.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, this is it.
Yeah!
What's it mean?
Loba's Cheek 69, 420.
That seems right.
Alright!
We can... We go to our favorite place.
Where's the sniper perch?
If I'm going to snipe, I might as well go here.
It's sniping time!
Alright.
This is my only safe place.
This place made me live the longest.
So like, I feel the safest.
Honestly.
This is like, the only place that I feel safe at the moment.
Enemies nearby?
Not anymore.
I don't think anyone lands here.
That's good.
Thank God.
Thank fucking God.
For now.
This place is my sanctuary.
Out of all the solo modes I played, this was the only area that I lived the longest.
So, I literally... I don't trust anywhere else.
Okay, let's see.
Let's do it.
We need an actual sniper though.
Like, I found like a repeater.
With the PK.
There's nobody here.
Thank God.
Oh.
Okay.
Either works, you know?
Where the fuck are the snipers?
How am I supposed to snipe if I don't have the one thing I need?
Are you serious?
Where the fuck are the snipers?
Wait.
You hear that?
Wait a minute.
I didn't loot that.
What are you doing here?
What are you do- This is my strat!
This is my strat!
Oh no.
That's fucking right, bitch.
Yeah, you think that's gonna stop me?
Oh.
Oh, guys, I broke-
Guys, it might have stopped me.
Guys.
Guys!
He's shooting my feet!
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, no way.
No fucking way!
That's actually nothing!
Oh my god.
I wouldn't have thought that would- Bro, this game fucking- There's no fucking way!
That's actually bullshit!
Bro!
Bro, stop!
I went through so much, bro!
It's not fair!
That's not fair!
I went through so much man!
I can't believe it actually stopped me!
What is this?
Bro, it actually stopped me.
Oh, it's here.
You thought tap street is gonna fucking save you?
Okay.
I might need shoes though.
Oh that's smart.
No!
Oh shit.
No no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no!
I'm so sad.
I got... I got fucked so hard!
You know what?
That... that bug, I think that was a good time to call it.
What a game to end it on.
Okay, guys, we're calling it here.
I have another stream later today.
In an hour, so...
I still can't believe... I can't believe that I'm hockey!
Why am I the one... why?
Anyway, we have a Tekken 8 stream next.
A great time though, playing a new season.
As always, everybody, say hi to DreamHackers.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Say it up for me.
Say it a little longer for me to play Tekken 8 for the first time ever.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Also, slightly new ending screen.
You'll see now.
Bye!